[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
go
[Music]
[Music]
oh man right at the end there
looks like we got the perfect setup
the perfect intro screen and then the
title card is kind of skewed it's all
good though you know
it is how it is what's up everybody
welcome to the saturday morning
live stream my name is clinton jones
y'all probably know that already by this
point um but it's been a minute it's
been almost a month since i've seen you
all and it is good to be back so
thank you for joining me
um
yeah it's been it's been a month i was
under the weather for a lot of the month
um and i feel like i'm just kind of
getting back into things
i finished the infinite journeys
breakdown you guys saw that it was a
that was a whole
that was the whole thing even making the
breakdown itself was the whole thing a
lot of work goes into those videos
um
shoot what else yeah today we are
this is gonna be an interesting one
y'all this is gonna be a very
interesting one because
for many reasons one i have a piece of
uh like i have a piece of art that i
want to make i had an idea that i wanted
to that i came up with a while ago and
it is to take a bunch of these
things
you know a bunch of plastic stuff that
we usually throw away we use it once and
we toss it
um
and to build
some sort of uh like sculpture from
these things
and i'm gonna get into
a lot of things i'm gonna get into my
love of penguins uh which might sound
very random but it's kind of all it all
connects i'm gonna also talk about
things y'all didn't know about recycling
which
also sounds probably a little random
um but yeah it's been a thing for me
ever since uh ever since i fell in love
with some penguins i was like you know
what i would rather
not have a penguin eating
this
um
so
it's not going to be like a really sad
intense stream i
definitely want to keep it fun you guys
know how we do it
but that's where the idea came from and
i'll get into it once we once we get
going
um sanctivan thank you for the super
chat that's very kind of you you said
love the breakdown thanks for hosting
creating such an amazing challenge
looking forward to the next one
yes i'm looking for the next one too and
it'll be coming around the corner um
a little later in the year
i'm very excited for it
um yes recycling is cool i'm down down
to recycle
did you guys know that most of the
plastics that have the little like
recycling sign on there it's not a
recycling sign that is actually like a
label of what kind of plastic the
plastic is made from
and there's seven of them i believe at
least in the united states
you'll see the little triangle you'll
see a number in the middle ones and twos
those are recyclable
three through seven those are not
recyclable you cannot recycle them if
you try and recycle them
they're at the recycling plant when it's
going down the conveyor belt they're
gonna take it off and they're gonna
throw it in the trash
um which is crazy
think oh it has a little recycling thing
you can recycle it
no it doesn't work like that it's a
little bit more confusing unfortunately
um but let's get into the art here okay
um
this was the thumbnail you all saw i had
to put this together for the thumbnail
and it's basically
fish i got this like little skeletons
and i just modeled a bunch of little
plastic utensils
and populated the skeleton with these
plastic utensils so we're going to start
by
modeling
a number of
these items in c4d and of course you all
can follow along in blender
um
maya 3ds max
whatever the heck y'all are using it
doesn't matter we're just here to create
some cool stuff together
and i i hope to
finish a piece of art by the end of the
stream that's the goal and hopefully
update the thumbnail with something
with i don't know we'll see
um so yeah we'll model a number of these
here and we're going to
populate it uh on a number of different
creatures because i think it's a very
impactful message the odd the message
obviously being don't throw your crap in
the ocean because it's gonna get up all
in the uh
in the bellies of some sea creatures and
some birds and uh they're gonna be
eating our plastics and then if you eat
fish you're gonna be eating a little bit
of plastic as well so it just uh it's
not good it's not good
um
so i guess
i guess uh i'll start modeling and then
i'll get into
why
i care so much about penguins
if you guys care about that i'm gonna
make a new scene
and i'm just gonna get started with uh
some of this easy stuff here
so let's see also who who is in the chat
today
who do we got any recognizable faces
or names um
y'all
i'm sure y'all have been here before
but y'all seem new to me what's up
everybody
so christopher woods
how's it going
exceed you started learning 3d after
seeing one of the challenges that's
awesome yeah it is tough
it is very tough but as long as you keep
it fun uh i think you will be in a good
place
um
do i continue or do i do i plan to join
another studio or continue freelancing
i'm gonna continue doing my thing you
know i got my youtube channel
and i'm gonna keep growing it i'm gonna
keep doing my thing
penguins for life agreed
saint even i agree
you collect your wooden sticks that you
stir your coffee with at the office
that's awesome maybe you can make some
sort of sculpture from it or something
that'd be sweet
um is everyone ready to model are you
guys ready to model hey visual what's up
dude got one of the moderators up in
here of course sodamonte behind the
scenes right now
uh helping me out with the stream we got
mdk
you see
what's going down
can i publish a spotify playlist you
know i actually do have a spotify
playlist it's an ambient playlist if you
look up
ambient for vfx
and reflection or ambient for reflection
in vfx and it's no spaces it's just
underscores
uh between the words and an and sign
and there's about six hours of ambient
music on there
who else do we got we got a lot of
people up in here
um
coming from solidworks to blender
nice nice
all right y'all
let's do it
let's start modeling
we'll start with this basic little cup
i'm gonna keep this stuff real low poly
because we're gonna be populating
tens of thousands
of these things
so i don't want to
crash the system too hard
all right uh let's just start with a
straight up disc
all right and we want it to scale so i
always pop in
a figure
and i'd say that to go containers
probably about that small
all right so this all started for me
when i was in my hometown atlanta
georgia
and i was with my fiance at the time or
fiance now girlfriend at the time which
sounds really weird to say girlfriend
um because it's about to be wife
so
we were at the atlanta aquarium
and i wanted to make it like a little
extra special
instead of just going to the aquarium
she was in town to visit my family for
christmas
um
so i thought hey why don't we just do a
penguin visit
thing
right we can meet a penguin
for however minute however minutes they
have their little program for it maybe
it might be like a little 30 minute
session or something we had our time
slot 2 30 whatever
we'll be there
so
they put they bring us into this tiny
little room
and
we wait for maybe five minutes there's a
couple other people there
and all of a sudden
it's like waiting in the doctor's office
and then you wait for the doctor to get
there but instead of the doctor around
the corner walks a penguin
the cutest little
little bud just waddling up to us so
curious and he just
hops up onto this little table in front
of us
and just starts looking around and like
flapping his fins and like
shaking and dancing and doing his thing
his name was obi and we totally got a
picture with him absolutely
and it was just like the best thing ever
the like from the moment i saw the
penguin
no joke i got teary-eyed i was like this
is the best
thing ever oh my god
um
so pretty much that was the moment i was
like penguins are the best
i can't get enough
and we got some like plush penguins and
everything
that we still have
and
from there
every time it just became a thing we're
like let's go to an aquarium let's hit
up an aquarium
and
we would visit the penguins
and i could just sit there forever you
know and just watch these penguins do
their
thing and at one point it was probably
the long beach aquarium
here in california
that i read
on like a little info thing or like the
trainer comes out right
um
and it said something about
the penguins like they love small fish
very shiny
small fish they eat them whole and
they just go as go in as a pack into the
ocean and just tear up some fish
right
but
because there's plastic in the ocean
and plastic can be very shiny
they sometimes mistake the plastic for
fish
and when you start digesting
plastic well you don't digest plastic
they mistake it for food and they think
they're filling up but they're not
really
and i was like heck no
i'm not gonna have
one of these sauce packets
get stuck in a penguin's throat or have
them think it's food
you know so
that's that was it for me i was like all
right
that's it
also i love taking care of myself and
being responsible
for myself
let's move on to
what do you all want to do next
in the chat here
uh
these are the same
we did this one already
we can do
any number of these lids we can do
straw we can do one of these guys one of
these guys
what do you all think what do you want
to model next
so
first person first person to say
whatever it is
first person
bottle soto you don't count
sorry that's so mean
um
flossy boy all right adam flossy boyd
let's go with the flossy boy sorry sorry
that was mean i apologize
um
so
yeah the floss one that's a good one
because
what was i saying okay yeah um being
responsible yes all right so
um how about this how about we do it
like this instead of making a new scene
every time i'm going to stay in this one
scene and
um
sauced up
saucy
bottom
sauce pack
and we'll just hide it because our scale
i think we have our scale set already so
i can
work from here
all right
we get that spline tool
turn on snapping work plane grid snap
and we'll go to town um
so yeah i'm down for just being
responsible for myself and all the stuff
that i use
i like being organized like i got like a
little ocd
kind of a thing um
so
yeah it
it's a thing
um
and
what really did it for me uh after a few
aquarium visits was i visited um
which aquarium was it
may have been the monterey bay aquarium
and
they had a book
called can i recycle this
and i loved it so much i pinned it in
the just in the uh description
down below
and it was basically a book it wasn't a
long boring book on recycling no it was
a very fun picture book
essentially
um
on recycling and it was a list of all
the things that you can recycle and a
list of all the things you can't recycle
and kind of how recycling works
in general
and i thought that was just super cool
i loved it i consumed that book
um
i love
self-help kind of books because i feel
like i'm just leveling up every time i
read one
and for me
i was leveling up with my knowledge game
there on recycling
and i thought i knew
you know how to recycle but
apparently not after reading that book
it's crazy that's how i learned about
like
the plastic numbers you know i mentioned
the beginning of the stream that there's
seven of them
and you can really only
recycle
ones and twos at least in the us
i think there's different naming systems
on different parts uh of the world
but
i just thought that was crazy because
the other stuff
the other numbers right three through
seven they're made from other things
that
aren't that straight up are just are not
recyclable
um let's do an extrude on this that is a
thick pick all right um
what is that like point two
nah not even
um let's go to 0.05 yeah that works
that's perfect and let's just get a
little
center this guy up and
get the actual floss the actual floss
nah not a cylinder let's just do it with
a plane
now let's do it with a polygon excuse me
because we're not going to see too much
detail
it's more gonna be like uh
you know maybe maybe we do it
with it with a rectangle
let's get that over there
and let's just take that whole face and
drop it down
yeah
you see it's clipping if i get any
closer it's because it's just really
small so if you hit ctrl d you can set
the view clipping to small
and i'll take care of that
bam that's good for the floss pick um
yeah that's that's good
alt g to group
[Music]
so the whole thing res with recycling if
you all didn't know there's the three
r's which sodamonte reminded me
yesterday when we were getting prepped
for the stream and he was like what were
those three r's and i was like oh shoot
what were they
and it was reduce reuse and recycle
and i think it's like in that order too
so the first thing is like reducing all
the amount of plastics that you use
reducing the amount of things that you
use and i'm all about
you know minimalist kind of style
i'd rather have less than more
um
what's her name mary kondo
the whole like uh
if it doesn't spark joy throw it away
i'm all about that i think i've owned
like three copies of that book it's so
good
it goes back to my ocd i'm like obsessed
with
being organized and
uh yeah period
so
she's really uh
she's really awesome if you guys don't
know about her i should pin that book as
well
um what's next y'all you tell me first
one
that calls it out
we're modeling it
um
so reduce right reduce the amount of
stuff that we all use that we throw away
reuse
that's the biggest one reusing things
that's like
number one
to having less stuff going to the ocean
the six-pack all right we're doing it uh
melvin let's go let's go sun
all right where are you at six-pack
all right how am i gonna do this i have
to i don't know if i can talk
and model that i have to think about
this um
[Music]
okay i think i have an idea
[Music]
let's do a plane
[Music]
let's go two
to one
yep
ah
12 and 24 maybe no that's way too much
six
and 12.
nah i need to go even more like bam
something like that perhaps
no
i can't do 1.5
uh
something like
that
then we got the in-between stuff
we can try this
i'll duplicate it just in case
okay um
and this doesn't need to be perfect low
poly
we're not gonna see
really any detail
um so i just need to be aware of that
learning from past mistakes y'all
it's a good thing
the grid is getting in my way get out of
here
uh
world grid
that's the work plane
and the axis is getting in my way too
all right
get these guys out
something like that
um we can chop these maybe down the
middle
chop
this down the middle
and
open
this up a little bit
let's uh
let's open this touch
i think you all can kind of get the idea
of what's going on here
let's go to 1
35
oh but then that
all right how about this
let's get real close
all right then we can open these up and
then we can scrunch it back in
1 30.
if anyone knows a way to do this all at
once in c4d please tell me
because i need to know
y'all i recognize i am not the best 3d
modeler
um though it is what got me into 3d in
the first place
there are some guys ben tate and chris
tate
and they made tutorials for
cgtuts.com maybe they also had their own
website they modeled like turrets and
some cool sci-fi stuff and some
architecture stuff and it was they did
3ds max tutorials and
man they were the best
i mean that's like
that's that's darn close
mirror yeah i could mirror
but um
let's see oh yeah
get rid of these guys
bam
that's pretty much
that's pretty much it
for me um i mean we could go the extra
mile
and do
you know some of this might as well
we're here
and i'm just eyeballing this
sweet um
and we can probably
[Music]
give it a little thickness
so i'll just select everything
hit d
and just a touch
make sure we add caps
if you want you can hold alt
throw in a subdivision surface
but i kind of like the low poly look
or maybe we just do subdivision of like
one
[Music]
something
that's something i don't think we need
to go too
too much
more on it i like the low poly let's
keep it like that
okay uh
six pack
sweet we got our floss
thing
which somehow how did that get massive
i like that and
well what the heck
oh there we go
bam
all right
what's next y'all you call it
we got one of these we got some lids we
got a straw and we have utensils and a
water bottle first person
melvin you got the last one
let's see what the stream says
first person to call it
strawboy all right make a row nut this
is gonna be a quick one
straw i'm going blind i'm gonna look
um
i would assume a tube
and let's go
give it some height
that's pretty much perfect
and
oh you know
hold on
maybe a better way to do this
is with a spline
[Music]
turn back on the snapping
and we go
boom
boom
right and then
we just chamfer
this guy
bendy straw
cool
and let's throw it in a
well first we need
a circle spline
scale that way down
and then both of those
go into sweep
what is it uh ctrl alt if you hold ctrl
alt together
it'll throw both of them in
to the sweep
t for scale
and we just bring down
that straw and let's get up in here
because there's some stuff going on in
here right
um if we set this to
uniform
where are you
uniform
a little jinky but we're gonna be way
out there so it doesn't matter
um let's make this editable
and honestly let's take down
[Music]
zarik what's up dude
i'm keeping it real
by the day at least i try to i
appreciate you very much thank you for
the super chat
good stuff
all right
let's try and take down
um the amount of like
edges there we go yeah yeah
boom
right keeping it low poly and then let's
just make some chippy chops
up in here
chop
and get rid of snapping
okay and we can probably do
yeah just up in here i'll hold shift you
can see how it snaps to these different
quadrants this is right in the middle
and i'll add
i don't know what five okay and we'll do
the same deal here
five
cool and
i am going to
hit u l
and just grab every other one
and this probably is not gonna work
because well you know what
that is fine
that is absolutely fine
looks like the shading is off a little
bit i can get rid of all these uh
selection tags i don't need all those
i can take this angle down
i'm cool with that i know it's like a
little low poly but
it's kind of the style we're going for
all right who is next oh no
how could i
it's a straw
no caps no thank you
boom
what's next y'all
straw is done
oh a smooth might fix it okay
i'll try that
um
all right i see
starting
starting now from here
boom
next one i see from that dash
i am modeling
the bottle bridgey is done
people been asked people been requesting
that bottle the bottle is in high demand
these days
very high demand
y'all are like how the heck is he gonna
model
a bottle
i can't possibly fathom
this is guys it's happening
we're modeling this bottle
okay
um
cylinder
yes
indeed
it's kind of a big straw isn't it
all right
all right more recycling facts
what else
so
personally like i started replacing all
the things i started noticing
all of the things
that i would use once and throw away
and
i was like okay
just one thing at a time it could be a
very
overwhelming feeling being like
shoot you know like when you research
into this how much plastic is in the
ocean
it's not chill there's the giant
like
there's a
giant pile of trash a giant pile of
plastic in the ocean
and it's like micro particles that you
can you probably can't even get with
like a net or something
they're so fine
and
um
you know what there's a better way to do
this
so i'm like how do i how do i like not
have trash go into the ocean
because you can only do what you can do
personally you can't
control what other people do
et cetera et cetera right so it's like
what can i do personally to feel better
about this
and let's turn snapping back on
so what i
what i um
[Music]
what i realized was like okay
you know we're talking we're modeling a
water bottle right now right
and
i was like well i i don't need to go
through
water bottles
every time i'm thirsty how about i just
buy
a water bottle you know
you can get a water bottle
um
so you're not throwing water bottles
away and it's cool like you get to have
your own water bottle it's very handy i
bring it with me everywhere kind of like
can't live without my water bottle at
this point
um
when i don't have it i'm like crap
i i need my water bottle
so that was like one thing that was one
thing i like sweet okay so by me
you know
having my water bottle
i don't have to get plastic bottles
anymore
so you kind of rule that out
um
and then you kind of just go from there
you know like well what else
all the things that we're modeling today
these are all single use
items so when i'm if i get takeout
uh i say no thank you i don't need these
i have silverware at home you can keep
them
uh we talked about the water bottles i
have my own water bottle um coffee this
one's tough because like some stuff
looks like plastic
and
seems like you can recycle it but
you can't
so the more you kind of look into it the
more you'll know and the more you'll
learn um just like with anything
and i know that with some coffee cups
like starbucks or you know
whatever company
their paper cups are lined with plastic
because
so the coffee's so hot it's just gonna
boil right through if it's just like a
made from a paper bag so you just gotta
watch out for that
um
coffee this is more of a thing where
like you can bring your own thing just
have them fill it up
um
or
get it for there so they serve it in an
actual
like mug
i mean same deal here when i go to in
and out i'm like yo i'm good on the
water
i don't need the water
um because i have water at home or if i
have a water bottle
these guys are darn tricky
because when you go to earth cafe and
you need that fruit tart it comes in a
freaking thing
and you know what's the most jacked up
thing by the way is when
they have like
this right they have like a to-go thing
and this isn't just this isn't earth
cafe or whatever i'm not calling out any
specific place
it's everybody and they give you a to-go
thing right and it looks like it's
compostable it looks like it's just made
from the earth it's got like trees on it
and stuff
um it's all like matte finish you're
like oh this is nice
and then it says it has the recycle sign
and then it has a five written in it
you're like god
why why why would you have a tree
on it and make it feel like it's
compostable but it's a number five
plastic which again we talked about it
number five plastics are not recyclable
one and twos are three through sevens
are not
generally right
um so
that's annoying it's really annoying and
it just comes down to like
you know the the company the the plastic
company making it it's like no it is not
recyclable stop tricking us into
thinking it's recyclable because it's
not it's just gonna go in the trash
um straws
you know i just don't use them
i just don't really use a straw
if someone gives a straw to me i'll be
like yeah i'm good
keep the straw
we got super chats up in here
um
oh
cold back if it isn't my favorite artist
i appreciate that i do what i can
um
how am i keeping cheers from denmark i'm
keeping
just fine uh thank you for asking i've
never heard that phrase before i like
that
how am i keeping i'm keeping well man
um i got i got a ps5 yesterday
so i'm excited to take elden ring from
the ps4
to the ps5
um so i'm i'm doing pretty good
uh i'm just recovering from being sick
over the last
week or so
so uh
you know i'm doing better i'm doing
better thanks for asking i appreciate
you thank you for the super chat very
very kind of you and then we have
another one we got
stiles morales i see what you're doing
um
you can't thank me enough for all that i
do
it's because of you and the guys at
corridor
that i'm taking this journey into 3d and
vfx yes
yes yes
it's a fun journey my friend it is a
very very fun journey
um
my my
main piece of advice is to just keep
doing what is fun for you
and you're gonna go to the moon all
right
as soon as it becomes a grind ask
yourself
well
am i
learning at least
um
or am i progressing
[Music]
you know that then maybe it could be a
grind
there it's a it'll be a great i promise
you it'll be a grind at times i promise
you
but just remember we're doing it because
it's fun
um
what else
[Music]
um
okay
neko how oh that's a good question how
does prf screen not go away
when i click back on c4d um it's because
it is in
uh on top mode or stay on top mode or
something
uh mode if you go to mode
always on top control shift a
yeah that's a good one
good one for sure
um back to the stuff yeah straws i just
don't ask for straws i don't need them
if someone gives me a straw i'll just
have i'll i'll have them take it back
because you know it's coded i don't want
to be touching it and flinging it back
at them
um
i hadn't seen one of these in forever
use the
use a boxed six-pack thing if you have
to
sauce packets man sauce packets these
are tough um yeah i get them when i go
on uh
take out usually i'll just ask for one
thing of sauce they try and give you
like 20 sauces on my knowledge just give
me one
or start making my own sauce
you know we're all at different levels
um
from my experience the top
this lid on top is a number one so it's
recyclable this base piece is a number
five so that goes in the trash
unfortunately
now the smaller the plastic gets the uh
higher chance it'll fall through
the
conveyor belt you know when it gets to
the recycling plant so what you can do
and this is something i learned from
that book is
take uh smaller plastics and put them
inside of larger ones so let's say for
instance this was a number one
which they're usually number five
they're either fives or ones
um
if it's recyclable
i'll put these lids
up in here
and just close it up right so when this
goes through the plant like this will
make it over the conveyor belt
and it'll have its little recyclable
buddies inside
you can do the same with like uh
beer bottles inside of like tomato cans
same deal and then these guys um
god these are so convenient
they're so darn convenient
it's a shame
um
i got one for valentine's day i believe
or no it was a christmas perhaps
and it was like a reusable one and it's
just unfortunate because like the floss
breaks so easily and i'm like dang so i
tried just using uh just back to normal
string floss again
so
yeah i'm just trying to find ways that i
can take these
single-use plastics and reuse because
we're still at the reuse part of
reduce reuse recycle
so how much can you reuse your stuff
the list goes on it's really fun
actually to find out how many things you
can reuse
but let's get back to it y'all let's get
back to it
where are we at
where there you are
all right let's hit it with a lathe
whoa
that needs to be in the center
um let's
center this bad boy up
boom boom boom
all right shape's a little funky
i could bring this picture into c4d but
i'm a little lazy
right now
back
boom we get that chamfer tool
uh
scrunch these guys
in let's get rid of the y
maybe before we do that
we scrunch
chamfer
that guy
and for the bottom
it's kind of a thing down here so i'm
probably going to make this editable and
then start making some slices
um
let's see
yikes
adaptive is good
all right i'll make that editable
we don't need those
tags there um let's just make some
slices up in here
get rid of grid snapping and let's just
make a couple
cuts
we'll go
that's where that'll be this is kind of
before
the lip there yep yep
and we'll do
let's see one there
one there and i'm just eyeballing it one
there
oh normals are all jacked okay
huh am i getting like double something
huh
you are we'll flip normals you
what is
where are you normals normal rotate
normal move
align normals ua
it looks it looks like we have one let
me go back
because it looks like
normal caps
start and end cap
oh it's doing a weird thing here
where it's like you see there's geometry
inside
we do not
want that at all
why is it doing that is it because
our spline is not set up properly
perhaps oh it's because lathe needs to
be half
that's why
you're probably telling me in the chat
all
right um
what's the best way to do this we'll add
a point
bam and then we'll
turn on snapping
nope
add a point then we'll zero these guys
out
and then delete
holding shift
bring down to zero so they're perfectly
in line and then we will just zero them
out
and then
hopefully
we can just
yep do that and now our lathe is working
properly i'll make it editable
and now we should be able to select
everything and it looks normal yes
indeed okay
all right
i'm gonna get the bottom in a minute
so i know we still gotta do that
sweet
after this i'm gonna model the
utensils and then we should probably get
to
making some art huh
all right
smooth throw smooth on it
hey that's
that's smooth
we got a super chat save polar bears
what is up that's a very fitting name
for today's stream what's going on you
started your first 3d work on infinite
journeys and since noticed a motivation
to work on both 3d and 2d art yes that
is a very good thing
uh really appreciate the super chat
thanks for sharing that little piece of
info there yeah man that's great um keep
it up seriously
like i said the more fun we have doing
this
the better y'all are going to be the
further y'all are going to go
um all right let's just do a real quick
janky thing down here uh because it does
not need to be perfect and we gotta get
a move on so i'm gonna do a little bit
of this and a little bit of
that and that okay
let us
think about this
do
mm-hmm
because not all of these go down like
that
um it's like
[Music]
maybe
like two
or every third one
yeah that that works out
let's see and is it a bevel
and i believe these should
scrunch
oh man
extrusion yes
come on now
only i knew how to use that bevel tool
um because they should they should like
scale
down while they do this
the tension
y'all probably going crazy right now
all right
i'll do it the old janky way
and i know you know what this actually
might work because
yeah that kind of works
it is what it is
and then like these guys can kind of go
in towards each other but i'm already
getting detailed too much detail
too much detail let's see
that's what i want
i want that plus
apologies y'all have to apologize for my
horrible modeling skills here let's
scale that in
nice
we don't need that i don't think so
[Music]
yeah
good eat enough
uh i could throw it in
something like that but
yeah
looks okay i need to move on let's just
get a cap and call it a day
um i'll just do it from here
so
[Music]
mn will get rid of cuts there
or lines rather and then uh ms will
bevel
yeah that's good
then maybe we just bevel out
this bit here
wow that looks horrible
jeez
why does that look so darn bad
oh my god
i could maybe try and throw a bevel
modifier in it
it's not really helping me either
i'm just gonna leave it as is
all good
ain't gonna be perfect
all right
next i'm doing the utensils because
we gotta this is like number one
um
all right
let's hide all that stuff
grab that spline tool turn on snapping
and let's make a knife
i'm gonna go
all the way over here
[Music]
maybe to like here
something like that and
boom
okay
this guy we can
bring
all the way in
come on now
bam
and we'll chamfer these guys
maybe this one first
this can probably just come up
like that that works
uh and then the back will also chamfer
boom
that's nice mike what's up dude um love
in the render challenges never seen a
more beautiful display of art in my life
heck yeah man that's awesome
i was wondering if you're up for
collaborations partnerships on future
render challenges can we chat um
so you can send me an email um on my
channel i believe i have a business
email on the youtube channel you can hit
me up on discord um if it is for
business stuff
usually um it depends like um
trying to remember the last time i did a
collaboration with someone i should do
more
but yeah it really depends
uh on the project usually it's
it'd have to be like the perfect idea
with the perfect person and the you know
et cetera et cetera
but
i'm open to whatever you want to throw
at me uh so
let me know dude i appreciate the super
chat thank you very very much
very kind of you
still trying to figure out how to
pronounce punisher pwn pwn
all right
let's throw an extrude
on it
by the way around
yeah that's good
i believe we can make this
editable
get rid of all that stuff
and
let's just do a little thing
up here
mw for extrude inner
oh no
we'll fix that
um ooh we got some stuff up here too huh
how about we just don't go as far how
about we just do it like that
and d
for
extrude
we'll go in
i guess it's not really on there but hey
you know what
people get the idea
um
that is
the knife i'm gonna worry about the
edges because we're just kind of going
off of silhouettes at this point
based on what we're going to do with it
here in a second
um
let's do the spoon
next
all right what's the best way to do
this spoon okay
maybe i'll do half of it
mirror the other half extrude it
and then work with that geometry so
let me start over here like
this
kind of goes
a little wider
here and then back in
and then we got
spoon shape
maybe it's a little further out
something like that
then we close it
um
do we close it no i believe we don't
close it
get
yep
all right um
let's chamfer some stuff real quick
boom
that actually needs to be a lot more so
just crank it like that that's good
and i'll check for this guy
as well
sweet
j volto what's going on
much appreciated with that super chat
there uh it's been a while since you
watched a stream i remember the old days
uh the keypad and the doorknob dang
those were some old days i was in a
different place
all a whole different time of life
during those streams
now you're in a deep face if i need any
hey good to know very good to know those
are that's some crazy dark magic right
there man
super cool stuff very good for vfx too
um all right so this needs to be
thrown into some symmetry we use
snapping because these points need to be
at zero in order for symmetry to work
properly
so let's hold alt and throw it into
symmetry
and
adjust the axis yep much better
cool and then we can throw that into an
extrude
um
you should be able to
unless we just make that editable
control a uo to get rid of any
overlapping points we don't have any so
that's good
and that is optimize uo is optimized if
you have any overlapping points it will
get rid of them
why is that not working
is it
huh
i don't know why that's not working
huh
super weird
is it like
not closed or something
two points that's why there's two points
right there so uo should work but it's
not
so i need to weld this
bam
and i would assume oh it's broken up
here
crazy
uh
that is one point so it should work now
yep
sweet i will make that editable
um
and let's figure out how we're gonna do
this
spoon
here how are we gonna do this
hmm
oh louie good question how to get the
info up there if you hit uh
shift v
it'll bring up these uh the viewport
kind of settings and whatnot and if you
go to hud
then you can check
where are you
selected points selected edges selected
polygons select end guns frames per
second is a good one to have
uh total points total edges total
polygons
so you can kind of select whatever you
want and that stuff will pop up here as
needed
soft selection okay but i need to get
the middle this it needs to be like a
bowl
situation i wonder if i can like
hmm
there's probably so many ways of doing
this
all right i'm gonna use a knife tool
um visible only i'm gonna uncheck that
and i gotta make some geometry
because i think soft selection will
probably be the best bet
uh one thing i did actually uh going
back to the recycling stuff
is when i go rock climbing
we usually like to cook up a nice little
meal
while we're at the top of a climb and i
bought one of these like bamboo utensil
sets
so that's a really good way to get some
reusable
portable utensils
it's basically like camping
pretty much like you got all your stuff
when you go camping if you guys go
camping
and when you go camping you also
don't leave any trash behind
hopefully if you're a decent human
human being
there's a thing about litter yo if
litter bugs yo
that
is
that's a move oh my god
that's a move
i don't see why anyone think they can
throw trash out a window
from a moving car
that's that's like next level rage right
there for me
okay let's grab some of these points
yeah
let's just grab
these two
right in the middle
we're gonna go soft selection based off
of one of y'all's suggestions
um
please tell me i went through yes thank
god
all right we'll get that
and we'll get these
we're going to move them down
off selection we'll enable it i think
it's going to be a dome
let's
bring it on in
that should be good
we want the outer edge to stay
i don't know where it is
with can you like
open it up
hmm
hmm
gonna work them settings just right
[Music]
could you imagine a spoon like this
he'd be like what the heck
or a spoon a spoon like this
like man
not again
so i'll just go a little bit of time so
i'll
decrease the radius increase the
strength
decrease the radius
increase the strength
i mean
it's kind of a spoon
how about this how about we try and get
the bell
curve correct
like that and then
we go back in for
this bit
and deselect
uh
dislike this stuff maybe
and we try
let's do
a radius of
two
lower that
strength
oh it's getting all that stuff okay we
gotta get rid of this too
and maybe we just try and like
flatten that out what's up
god
brutal
hmm
yeah you know hey when you're right
you're right that's a good idea
that's a good idea
it is a shallow spoon
but i think people get the point
i'm chilling with that
all right and then finally guys we have
a fork
and then it's time to start
building stuff with all this
let's take that spoon
make it knife sized
sweet
[Music]
mads i appreciate that i appreciate that
you're gonna get some cereal with that
spoon that's a good time
that's a very good time
okay
let's try the fork
in a different way
all right actually i'm gonna start it
with a plane no a polygon
and i'm only going to work on
half of it so i'll make that editable
go to line mode hold shift bam
get these points
we don't need soft selection anymore
we'll hit some symmetry
bam all right so now everything we do on
one side we'll have on the other
so
open it up just a little bit
[Music]
grab that line hold ctrl
i'm gonna
come out to the side here
grab that line hold ctrl
boom and then it kind of like
tapers in a little bit it looks like
just like that
cool
now we need
a couple cuts
[Music]
along this axis here so we have
think about this
how about before i taper it
[Music]
all right i think that's what we need
right there
get rid of that
oh we need two gaps okay
so that'd be
three
okay just like that
one two
and then these guys need to
scale from here all right
what
why
why
that's so annoying
i thought that would definitely work
it seems
it is not going to work
[Music]
something like that
these are a skew for some reason
straighten those guys up all right
awesome
and then it looks like these are also
skew
so i'm hit t and just hold shift bring
it to zero
all right so it looks like this one kind
of comes in
this also comes in a little bit
and then this one
seems to taper as well
but more so
up here
[Music]
oh my god
goodness gracious
evolver
yo
yo
thank you
jeez
thank you for that super chat man
goodness gracious
too many weeks you've missed man it is
all good
it is all good
hats off to you man the chat's like yo
that's crazy
thank you so much
thank you so much chris i appreciate you
man
that is awesome
that's very very cool
i appreciate you very much dude
we got a fork we're working on this fork
chris
it's janky
it's all good
it is all good
maybe that looks more like a fork
oh the geometry
who that geometry
brutal
but you know what
it's all good
it's all good because right now
it's gonna be okay
so i'm not trying to win geometry awards
right now
yep
yep
all right
yes i know the fork is flat
we'll get there
yo you'll see you want to see bad
geometry watch this
check this out
sorry to see over my microphone
all right it's a fork okay
now we gotta fork it up all right um
what does that mean you ask well
gotcha
we need to bend it you know
let's go with symmetry
no not symmetry we need
extrude
why is extrude not working
we're going to make it edible
editable
and make sure
that everything is chill
up in here i'm going to hit ctrl a to
select it all 203 points
uo
to optimize we went down to 201 that
means we had some overlapping stuff
um
y'all are
y'all are having a field day right now
with this fork
it's all good i'm not the fork master
okay
i know
i feel all y'all's pain it doesn't
matter
it doesn't matter
um all right why is extra not working
though
screw it i'm gonna just extrude it
root force bam
done
we got a fork okay doesn't look good
i don't care
um
let's
do a thing
maybe a cut there
maybe a cut there
let's not do it like that
bam okay
how bad can i make it at this point
that's what i want to know
let's see fork kind of like goes
how's the fork work
uh
we gotta get all this stuff
i just gotta get all this stuff in here
come down oh this is brutal y'all
can i just deform it to a spline
is that even a thing
spline wrap i'm gonna try it screw it
we're here might as well
um
this is hilarious y'all
my true modeling skills coming out right
now
um
it'd be like this right it'd be like
boom
boom boom
[Music]
boom
boom right
that's a fork
there you go
that's what we wanted to form it to
all right now do i even remember how to
do this
uh
[Music]
um
what is
the deformer what is it
i mean i could ffd it
blind rap
is spline wraps blind rail one of these
splines something in here
i can also just do
where is it
a line to spline
perhaps
or a line to path
i don't think this is it
now
what was it
spline wrap all right thank you good sir
oh i didn't have a cap on it
i have to redo that real quick
geez
man do we need a rail perhaps
there we go
bam
that's the jankiest fork
and
that's worse that's worse than the one i
did
the test one i did
for the thumbnail oh my god
oh
oh i'm keeping it
good
ready for supper
i'm into dinner okay
um
i've spent too long on this dang fork
y'all
screw it i'm redoing it just really
quick
another way
i'm not going to modeling y'all just
don't make fun of me please
all right
um
can't handle the pressure
how about this i'ma keep with the spline
wrap method
we are going to do a thing
here
boom
boom
boom turn off snapping
where i can
just
get up in there one two one two three
one two three four
we have spent too long
on this janky fork
so
[Music]
[Music]
let's see
[Music]
done
make editable
finished
we got a fork y'all
it's better than the last one
okay
so we have made it
finally
to this can go bye-bye
finally we can
call it a day on the modeling
and we can start making some art start
lighting some stuff
having a good did i delete the wrong one
no i did not
it just still looks a little janky but
that's okay
[Music]
all righty let's uh
just get the center points all figured
out here for this stuff
so we got the knife
um let's center that up
reset transformation
knife is good
spoon
center that up reset
spoon is good fork um i'm hitting what
is this tool this is the center axis 2
tool
bam you can hit shift c and look up
whatever you want in c4d center axis 2
and
reset transformation that'll zero out
the psr
we got a bottle we'll do the same deal
for all of this stuff
the straw
bam
reset
six pack same deal
floss we'll go ahead and um
bake that down
and the sauce pack
i'll probably keep the top and bottom
separate
[Music]
sweet so we got a bunch of stuff
to
populate
our scene with right
now
we can do this in a couple different
ways let's first set up our our studio
lighting setup okay
so
that's when the handy dandy grayscale
gorillas
plug-ins come in handy they have a light
kit pro setup they got a psych that we
can set up bam
very very simple very easy
they are the best
all right you can adjust this however
you'd like grayscale gorilla for the win
um
all right
kind of get with a big set here
and it's time to bust out octane
all right
right now
we got a plain old scene
let's first start with um no lights
that's how i like to work i like to work
with no lights so i'm gonna make an hdri
environment
and since there's no hdri plugged into
here it's just darkness right
we can have it set to a color if we want
but
i
want it to be black
um
oh my goodness
vj
verma
my friend
thank you for that super chat very kind
of you very very kind of you thank you
so much am i on
okay we're on auto focus we're good
we're good
um thank you all for sticking around
and watching me through that modeling
process i know it's not the best process
but you know what all good i just bought
a pack on modeling
in c4d so i'm excited to get through
that
it's about time
um vj thank you so much for that super
chat man as very generous of you very
very kind
um you and you and evolve are both thank
you guys so much super cool of y'all
um not even a message either just a
straight up support man thank you so
much
heck yeah
all right
let's get to it
let's get lighting
our scene
so we have this environment in here
let's go ahead and make an octane
light
i'm gonna rotate it 90 bring it right
above
bam all right
i think i'll go i'll go pretty big on
this
i'll take down
the power of this thing to 10.
and
let's go ahead and make a material for
our background so shift f2 will bring up
your materials
i will make
a make a glossy material
drop that on the psych
i'm gonna group all this stuff here
let's call this light
i'll make a camera i'll hop in it
this is our geo
now i'll put the side game at the light
as well okay
all right
let's just kind of set this stuff up
generally
you can actually just go with the water
bottle as a test
all right back to that material
i kind of want to go for like a dark
gray
it's way too
uh
way too shiny right now so i'm gonna
take the
roughness excuse me to 0.8
and maybe even the specular to like 0.5
or something
that's good for now
um
let's center up our camera
just line this guy up
and i'm gonna go for more of like a a
longer lens so
straight up just a 100
maybe a maybe a 80.
something like that
and we'll switch to path tracing so we
get the bounce underneath
looks much better
all right
so we can go update check we can turn
off camera that way we can actually hop
out of our camera and start placing some
lights
so we'll call this uh top is our top
light
and we can move this forward and back
kind of see
what it's going to do
and i'm just kind of eyeballing this in
here
uh hold ctrl it'll make a new one let's
rotate it 90.
and these ones i really just want to be
pretty thin
right that way just edge lights
that nicely we can even move it back
a little bit
three quarter
to really get that edge light um
it's called right
edge
we can turn this one up
bam that's a lot
we can do the same from the other side
too so control to duplicate
nice little edge light situation
we could turn this one
i mean we could do a lot of things
really we can make this
more of a warm color this one on the
right
more of a bluish color
and we'll rename our stuff because
it can get a little confusing
joshua what's up man
uh not everyone needs to be good at
modeling
agreed agreed
absolutely though it does help
certainly helps when you need to make
something custom
all right
i would also like to light
the background a touch too
so
i'm going to duplicate
this top light
and kind of just get it
pointed at the background
for kind of like a silhouetti
or a vignette effect
why is this not
let's make it a little smaller
and a bit more powerful
uh
yeah something like this we can turn it
down but let's try and get that
spotlight effect
all right so we want
something like
this but
a little softer
[Music]
[Music]
all right we can also take all these
lights and change them to uh
invisible so uncheck camera visible that
way
they don't block anything if need be
if they need to get up in the scene um
so we kind of have
our lights in place and we will mess
with these
and change their intensity depending on
what we need right so i'm actually going
to do one more light
right off center
scale down
this will just kind of be a general fill
light
if the foreground it gets a little dark
so i will take that down
to five maybe
and we can turn all of these lights off
and see what they do one at a time right
so
we have our top light
which well hold on
we need that okay yeah we have our top
light
we have a right edge
it's more of a blue we have left edge
it's more of a tungsten
we have a backlight
for the background of course and we have
a fill light just to kind of lift up a
little bit
um
that looks cool
that looks super cool
and we can
hit it
with an edge light
or a fill light let's see
wait no no no
see all that looks bad
but what i want to do
is just
have this edge light be more a little
sharper
almost like it's almost like a backlight
it's also really intense
all right
the top light does very nice
and the fill just to
lift it a little bit
all right
so now we can start
making some cool stuff all right we have
a pretty pretty nice studio set up
um it is a pretty small scale i'm
realizing now but i think we'll be fine
let's uh let's see what we can do
i downloaded some
[Music]
some models
let's see uh
vfx 3d models
cg trader
skeletons all right we got whale
skeleton
what is it just the bones hold on
uh
geometry yes i want geometry
huh
maybe i need to
look a little deeper download a
different file perhaps we'll come back
to that
i also have a fish
which you all saw in the thumbnail
we have
a crab
the crab i test it out doesn't crab
doesn't really work
it just looks like a mess
of plastic
um
we also have a bird the bird is pretty
cool
i feel like the bird works pretty darn
well
so maybe let's um maybe let's start with
the fish and then we'll go
we'll go from there
so let us see i'm going to
connect all objects and delete so it's
just one thing
tinum oh my god that is a name i've not
heard in a minute what is up man
um been a fan of your work for a long
time enjoy the weekly challenges also
any news on that movie you're working on
take care um no news on the movie i am
still writing
i've slowed down a little bit on the
writing since i you know
was under the weather a little bit the
last couple weeks don't feel good about
it um so i'm getting back into the
groove of things getting back into
working out
um and the writing is coming right
afterwards writing is is the hardest
part is so difficult that i think i've
said this before but
writing is so difficult
that
i know i can
do everything else after the writing i
can literally make this movie if i can
just write it that's how hard the
writing is that is the hardest part of
the whole thing for me
so
um what's most what's the most difficult
is the fact that like um there's a
million different ideas
and i'm like oh that'd be sweet oh this
idea would be sweet oh no that idea
would be sweet and it's all like part of
the same idea
and
getting to that v1 script
is just the biggest challenge i think
once i have a v1 then i can go from
there
but that v1 boy is it difficult um and i
will definitely be making videos on this
process all my on all my struggles with
it um
because it is
it's a lot if y'all are trying to
write a movie
i'd say start with a short film first
that would definitely be helpful
um
and then you know you can go from there
but
yeah
lots of uh
lots of good stuff lots of good things
to learn from
once i get through this process so i'm
gonna be documenting the whole thing
from start to finish
and sharing it with you guys here on the
channel
what else
yeah writing man writing oof
very difficult
very very difficult
all right
let's get this fish going right so i'm
gonna copy this thing
and we are gonna paste it up in our
scene
into that camera make sure we are
updating the camera
all right
um the water bottle can go
for now
let's get our fish
in here and i want to give it like i
want to put this fish on a stand i think
would be really cool
all right
um
so we want to take all of these objects
and
put them on this fish all right we want
to clone them onto the fish
so what we're going to do
is we're going to select all these
objects we're going to hit ctrl alt
ctrl alt
allows us to press the cloner button
here
and it's going to automatically put all
of them as
children of the cloner okay
now the viewport is going to get chunky
all right it's going to get ridiculous
so because because here's the thing look
let me take it one step at a time i got
my my brain goes in a million miles an
hour okay
let's take that cloner
and we'll take it from grid we're going
to take it to object all right we're
going to clone it on an object and it's
going to ask what object and we're going
to say
the fish which we should definitely
rename
to fish
um
so from here
we have this counter
we can crank it up
that does not look like a fish at all
right
um
so here's what we're gonna do the next
thing is to hide the actual fish
skeleton because i want to build the
fish from these pieces of plastic right
so
what we'll do
is
hide the fish skeleton
from our render by hitting this second
little button down here it turns green
and then hit it one more time turns red
you'll notice it disappears
from our render view i can take the
count down and you're not going to see a
fish hopefully we'll see a fish based on
these plastic pieces right
okay
but
if i take this up to like a thousand
the viewport is gonna get really chunky
and i've was tattooing tests at like
thirty thousand oh so we don't want to
see
any of the cloned objects inside of the
viewport so what we'll do is hide the
cloner
in the viewport and that's the top
button here so you see it goes green
boom then it goes red now i can take
this
this number
and keep in mind it says we're in
instance mode
um
render instance
works a lot better multi-instance can
work a lot better than that i don't know
the exact specifics of it but what i do
know is that it is referencing the one
object and duplicating them
as many times as you want so you
actually don't have a ton of geometry in
the scene
because it's instanced it's just
referenced that way right but i think
render instance worked nice for me
but setting it up this way the way we
have it right now
you're gonna have solid results you can
still see i can take this up to uh
20 000.
and the render is going to do its thing
right
and i can still move freely in the
viewport
and still get 47 frames a second right
so
bam ctrl shift z undoes camera motion
um now it doesn't look like a fish right
it looks like
kind of like a pile of trash
so
what we'll do
let's start with the fork the spoon the
knife let's get rid of the bottle
for a second
let's get rid of
the six
pack and keep it to
the straw
and the utensils and stuff it's starting
to look a little bit more like a fish
let's go ahead and hide all this stuff
from the viewport actually that's fine
all right ocd's got me i'm gonna get rid
of it all right anyway
we can see that the plastic pieces are
too big so i'm gonna the cloner
we'll go to transform and we're gonna
take these down we can try point one
and that looks pretty sweet
wow
that's awesome
let's do some color correction in the
camera so we'll go camera imager
enable camera imager
that's very interesting
this is a fish made from
pieces of plastic
that's super cool
um
we can up the count as well we can up
the size as well so that really looks
like a fish but you're not really seeing
the plastic pieces
um and i think
the best
version of this is a video to be honest
where it starts
like up close you know
i mean just that alone is super cool
that's pretty sweet
let's take this up to point two
but it's kind of cool that we like see
through the fish
so i'll go like .15 maybe because that
way it still feels like a skeleton
griffin yo
[Music]
griffin dude
shout outs to you man
what is up
thank you for the matcha money
that's really really nice of you if you
all don't know griffin from corridor in
the house right now
griffin i got something to show you dude
you recognize this guy
you recognize this guy
i know you're getting ptsd right now i
know you are
and i'm sorry i had to do that to you
just then
especially in a live setting
um
but
you know i got you know how it is dude
you know how it is
just remember your trash as smash bros
and that's coming from the heart dude
you know you know that's sincere
um and i only wish you the best
i don't know
i i'll be in the office next week i
think i'll
we'll settle the score we will settle
the darn score dude
uh everyone say hey to griff
super good dude
solid dude
griffin we're making uh
we're making
fish skeletons from plastic utensils
pretty dark huh
let's see if we can work in oh we have
our saucy bottom we got the saucy top
okay
um
shall we give
let's work on our lighting it needs a
bit more contrast so
here's what we will do let's remove the
fill light maybe
that's so crazy looking
i also want to darken up our background
so
let's go ahead and drop this
wow that's black
jeez
oh that's kind of cool
i wonder why
though
huh
oh it's that backlight that backlight is
blasting also the top light is blasting
too whoa that looks weird
that looks really nice
pop light
alone looks cool
the fill light flattens it out too much
i'm not really a fan
um
let's take this back to it
yep yep
something like that
um
the backlight
is pretty sweet but i think it's a
little too much so
we can drop it a touch
and yeah let's see let's see if uh the
specular is doing it
for sure yeah for sure maybe we can just
have a little bit
just a touch
awesome
and let's keep messing with our lighting
so we have an edge light honestly that's
not doing much for me
we have a right edge light
yeah
that's not doing much for me the top
light alone
wow that's crazy
it's so cool we can do with light i love
it
the backdrop we can take up to like
150 and get a nice silhouette
the foreground is a bit dark
that's super cool
uh so much fun to mess around with this
stuff okay let's go back to 50 on the
back light
our top lights doing most of the work
here
set that to like 15 maybe
we don't need the fill light let's take
our top light and see about moving it
backwards
it was better before
okay somewhere in here
it's just the top light and the back
light the edge or the fill i think
flattens it too much let's try
adjusting the gamma
or rather let's try adding
a lut a color lut
wow that's crazy
i'm just gonna go through these and see
oh that looks pretty sweet
that looks pretty sweet
wow
that's nuts um
i kind of want to build a stand for this
too because i want it to feel like it's
real you know we're also at 20 000
pieces
if we did 10 000
you'll be looking like this and maybe
5000
you can still kind of tell what it is
but let's try and see if we can't like
up the scale of these guys
maybe what we do
is we try and make these as big as we
can
while having the fewest amount
of pieces to actually like tell what it
is
because i want to be able to see like
the utensils
as well as the fish that would be the
perfect
blend and i feel like
that's a little big
that
to me is readable
that's readable
now what you could do
so the cloner right we have it set to
iterate and that's gonna go through i
believe like one two three four five six
one two three four five six one two
three four five six starting in the
order we have it fork spoon knife straw
floss pick sauce top saucy bottom it's
gonna go down that list over and over
and over again so there is like a
pattern to it you can change it to
random
and random
maybe is the move but iterate seems to
actually have more
more shape to it
and i just realized i went back
and it changed the seeds so we can
change the seed here
and go through until we have something
that we like
something that feels right
that looks pretty sweet i'm a fan of
that
um now what you could also do is use a
random effector and i feel like that
would make things worse but let me just
show you what is going on with the
random effector so with the cloner
selected
um i believe you can come to
where are you
here you are
boom
uh
random
boom all right so by default the
parameter is set to position of 50
centimeters
uh across everything
um
but we can zero out the position we can
mess with scale
i feel like that wouldn't be realistic
rotation would be realistic
if i set this to 180 across the board
right
it loses its form
it definitely loses its form
so i'm going to say rotation get out of
here
um
let's mess with
a material for the actual
um
utensils right
so
let's make a glossy material
very very very
simple
glossy material i'm looking at oh some
subsurface
yeah all right
so
let's do
just off-white
okay
and this
has a bit of roughness to it so i'm
going to say
like 0.2 maybe
0.3
maybe roughness yeah
um
oh man plastic bag jellyfish
that's a cool idea
yeah that's a cool idea
that's a super cool idea
i love that
um
okay
so
let's give it we need to make a
universal material because you can't do
subsurface on a specular or a glossy
material so we'll go universal
um and then we'll take the transmission
and we'll just kind of bring it up a
little bit
yeah nice
um
what else
ah there was one other thing there was
one other thing
maybe there wasn't let's apply that
to
the fork the spoon
the knife
you like the straw
is just kind of a straw
floss pick sure i feel like everything
can kind of have this material
you see it just got way brighter
so we could do one or two things we can
go into our camera we can take the
highlight compression down
and that will help a little bit
um
but i don't think it's too bright
it's not like overly bright or anything
one other thing too we can do
is we can go into the fish itself
and remove some parts of it that aren't
helping us
such as
these fins right here
all right these guys
they're not doing much for us
i'm gonna duplicate the fish
just so we have a backup
and i'm gonna go in here and just uh
select these
these pieces that we
that are kind of muddying up our render
i'll select all those
all right i'm just selecting a little a
little piece of it
as long as i get a piece
of every
uh
bone
there
then what we can do
i feel like is this helping i don't know
if that so hit uo
um or is it you know ui uo ui
u uy
if i right click and i find u y
where is that
u y
um it's going to you grow your selection
it may not be on here might be under
select
ah i can't find there it is grow
selection grow selection so you hit u
and y
um or maybe there's an easier way
u shift plus y now just ui
and you just do that a bunch and it's
going to expand itself
to the bounds of the geometry that you
have selected
i'm gonna delete it let's watch our
render let's a b comparison
enable a b
store it
right so this is
this is the same image right
and then if i delete
those parts
then we can see
is it helping us it might be helping us
a little bit it might be defining the
shape of the fish a little bit more it
brings out that like kind of bottom part
which i think is nice
uh melanie yo
long time no see what is up uh
hey clint c in the stream and how you
continue learning and challenging
yourself always makes my day that's
awesome i hope you're doing well kisses
and pets for gilbert absolutely
absolutely don't forget teddy too teddy
and gilbert
um
they will they will appreciate that very
much very very much they're probably
sleeping right now napping
on the couch or something
um but it's always appreciated
much love to the cats thank you melanie
is very kind of you um
with your super chats
thank you so much
stiles morales hey i'll recap for you so
i have all of the objects that i want to
clone across this material
inside of a cloner right
and that cloner is the mode is set to
object all right
and then i'm choosing
the fish as the object and it's going to
clone all of those
pieces of plastic across the fish
i have hidden
the skeleton
of the fish in the actual um the live
viewer
the render view on the right
and i've hidden the
duplicated uh or the cloned materials in
my viewport so that way i have super
smooth
fps
yeah so we're looking good i think this
is sweet i would love to build a little
stand for this thing
to make it feel like it's a real
like a real display a real piece so
let me uh let me actually brighten up
the background just a touch
all right
bring the fish up just a bit and then
let's make a
cube
make a very basic stand
let's give it a little bevel
and a couple cylinders
because i want this to feel like it
actually exists
like a
art museum or something
uh
sweet and then i'll make a material
i'll do specular
and give it some roughness
or just make it out of metal
or hold on
hear me out if you do
let's go grayscale gorilla hit their
plus library
um
tech products maybe
everyday materials
smudged brass
let's try that
whoa
that bounce back is so cool
[Music]
this one blew my mind all right so in
octane oh it's already done for us but
i'm gonna just show you it anyway
so if i select
or you have all these uh different
textures here right so if you select
everything instead of having to like
do the projection node and the transform
node one by one if you select it all
right click
go to add selected bam transform
done
same for projection done
can't believe how long it took me to
figure that one out
um
box projection is good
that scale looks not bad either
yeah i was feeling the same thing
um
so we could do
change this
color
correction you
like a green blue
or marble i could see a marble
um
let's hit their library again everyday
materials
um
masonry
marble
it's where they're more marble maybe
it's in
let's see let's just search
this is it huh
[Music]
what is naturally
blue and reflective
so we could
we could change the background
to a blue
wow that feels nice
that's crazy
imagine having that in your house
it'd be so weird
you know what set this over the edge
oh you know what that is over the top of
some caustics
in the background
or on the ground
um how would we do that
hmm okay
let's see so i know grayscale has these
gobo maps which is uh
if you're like what the heck is that
i'm about to show you
um i need to install it though
installed do i have them installed i've
never used them before
hdri paper metal
assets
surface imperfection go oh here we go
gobos caustic spam
all right
let's download this
uh-huh
install
yes please
gobos caustics
all right
i don't know i'm not getting a preview
oh there we go
okay so i've never done this before
and i hope it's this easy
because i'm very excited we put a plane
up above
right above our top light actually is
perfect
i'll make it as large as our top light
i'm going to apply this
caustics
texture
all right i'll make a new
diffuse material
and i will apply this caustics
texture as
an opacity
and then
i'll apply that to the plane
all right and if we
hmm
okay this should be working in theory
i think
you need a tiny light let me okay let me
try this let me duplicate the top light
that's our gobo light
and let me move it above
make it really small i think we have to
make it really small
and let's make it really bright
hmm is this working is this plane
why is that not working
[Music]
add the texture to the light itself
i never even thought of that
okay
yeah okay
[Music]
hmm okay let me scale it up
hmm
add it to the distribution of the light
instead of the texture okay
so hard to tell if it's working
ooh
there we go
i think that's working now
yes
wow
okay
yo that looks sick
wow
let me get our top light back in
the gobo should be a backlight because i
don't want to really hit our fish with
it too hard
[Music]
but i also don't want
the fishes
um
let's see
that's so cool
wow
[Music]
that's crazy i like that a lot
i feel like it'd be sweet on the
background too
maybe
maybe this goes on the background
let's see
oh
and maybe we take the
color of this light
more of like a green
all right and then this guy let's do
the other gobo
between one of these two
yeah
this one
[Music]
and then i want to tweak the lighting on
the fish a little bit more and maybe
switch out the base that stand
as well
that's horrible
ah no
just five
oh i forgot i saw the comparison
on wow that's what we had before
is what we have now
there's something cool about this plane
look too but
this is nice i think the stand i need to
switch out the stand
[Music]
you can see a wood base
yeah i could see a wood base um
[Music]
[Music]
okay maybe like a sand colored
one
okay a little bright
oh i know
i know
we should go to
quicksole
and grab a piece of driftwood
let's see uh 3d assets
nature
[Music]
tree
debris
maybe
like i don't know this feels a bit much
yeah that's a bit much
i mean like a nice
sturdy piece
maybe
maybe that but
like this
something like that oh this one
this is a good one
okay let's try that i'm gonna go with
the 8k
[Music]
let's try it
oh it's solo res
how
how is it so low res
huh
it's loud zero
um let's
convert the material to an octane
material
[Music]
there we go is the displacement it was
set to like
256k
that's much better
this is weird
albedo
this has an albedo has a roughness
why is that going into there
roughness i guess that's the specular
all right let's find the most natural
maybe like that it looks more like a
rock than a branch
there we go maybe something like that
i do this is that
the worst thing ever
do
[Music]
and we'll just do these from
like metal rods
[Music]
yeah something like that
and then we'll do
[Music]
let's see aluminum smudge what does that
look like
[Music]
yeah that works
that works
all right
uh is the focus not on the fish
i feel like it is
what do you mean the framing yeah i
gotta adjust the framing for sure
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
i feel like
um
yeah i feel the color of the wood
is too dark
you see what i can do with
the gamma
hmm this is tough
i mean the other option
because it's too i think it's too much
the stand is too much
the other option here is to do
um
like a plank
something like this
let's try it
because i like this color contrast
but these are just all
too thick like that might work
that could work too
but it needs
let's convert it
that's already better
um
the displacement
we need to set that to 8k
[Music]
it also needs a normal
[Music]
and i think the specular just needs to
be chilled out
okay let's see uh
go back to glossy i think the index is
all jacked no it's at one three
oh here we go now it's working now
i think octane's being glitchy on me
this needs uh
some color correction
a little saturated
why is that happening like that
because this is plugged into the
specular no i don't think so
now it looks absurdly shiny um
unless
that really goes into the specular it
just needs to be black and white
i don't understand why is that
why is that acting like that
[Music]
ah
have it
stop it
[Music]
how
just get
in here
all right now it just needs
less saturation
gamma
[Music]
that's not bad that's very subtle
that's very simple yeah i could see that
yeah it'd be sweet to like
do some charity stuff with this art
[Music]
i'd be super down
all right that's not bad that's not bad
we have the gobo
stuff going on in the background too i
think a touch of that is nice
um we could mess with
i wonder if the subsurface on the
plastic is too much because
we need a bit more definition let me
take that off
yeah it's really brightening it up
and i think the more definition the
better
or we could just use a little less
subsurface
that's pretty darn cool
um
another
let's see
what else could we do
[Music]
okay
all right
[Music]
hmm what do y'all think any ideas
yeah i thought about some rays
maybe we could do rays
[Music]
let's see is there a way
to turn this a little bit let's see
all right so turning it doesn't do
anything
hmm i wish i could like
flip it the other way
maybe the fish
and
the stand
just do that
and if we want to do raise let's see um
all right let's bust out volume
voxel size 100
that way the viewport can withstand it
and it just needs to be like in the
background
uh density point one
and let's look at
underwater reference for color
yeah the raise is a good move um
i see okay so it's blue
and white up towards the top
here's a good reference right here
just a simple color reference so
the ground floor is more of a green
all right
okay so let's try and switch the ground
floor to more of like a green color
and let's do the foreground gobo
a little bit
more intense on that
and then the background
or more so the fog
um
we will
scatter
that blue
yeah there we go
there we go
that's looking nice
[Music]
that looks great
okay and then that looks great
let's do a touch of work on the log
i think it needs
a little more brightness a little less
saturation
something like that
okay um let's try i mean we kind of
actually have some rays
coming in from up top here
let's see
where's the background gobo there it is
um where are those rays coming from
because we're kind of getting them is it
the top light
let's see let's do a test uh i'll make a
new light
rotate 90 scale it way down
we'll turn off surface brightness
and just
shine it
through the fog here
[Music]
oh you know what you know what all right
here let me delete this
because i think
i may be mistaken but i feel like i'm
seeing rays
they're very subtle
and i'm trying to figure out where it's
coming from
yeah that's what i'm thinking
it's probably the
uh
let's see it's probably
where are you
the foreground
light but it's so it's like right here
it's like barely in there
if i crank it
i wonder
and i wonder if i go with a more
contrasty
let me actually see if i can add
contrast to this
yeah we're definitely getting them
up top i see them
100
um
i think it's all good
um let's see
that's a little intense for me though i
will take that down to 15.
okay
it was looking pretty sweet
i think i'll flip the fish back
do
all right
three quarter angle okay let's try it
ah
we lose the shape of the fish
[Music]
i feel like there's so many ideas that i
could do with this
oh my camera did
i'm coming back
am i coming back
who knows
dude
rip
there it is i outlasted the camera
all right i'll probably just do
some touch-up work in photoshop i'll
sleep on it i really like this idea i
want to take this to the max
uh let's take this texture what what
shader there we go
sweet um
let's mess with our lights
just cuz
so that's the background light is off
background light on
pop light off
that's creepy
that's so cool
that is too cool
the gobo foreground has got to stay
that's awesome
so let me push the top light back
a little bit
and i still feel like the transmission
could come off
[Music]
styles
good to see you man
have a good one there goes the camera
again rip
oh
ah
okay
well it might be
nearing the end here
uh
enjoy your weekend styles
um
webcam overheating
oh i mean it feels kind of hot
maybe i'll let it chill for a second
um soto do you think you can just take
off my uh cam there for a second
test yeah what's up guys
all good so hey i'll just walk you guys
through this uh multi-pass thing because
they changed it recently in octane
so
under render settings at the far end the
render aov group uh if you choose octane
render and you choose the render aov
manager
then you can start choosing your stuff
so i want a z depth let's try a z depth
pass yeah
i'll double click that yep we got it
good to go
now if we go to render aovs you can see
z depth i can hit this drop down bam and
this took me forever
to figure out because before it was like
in the octane settings here it was down
here the z depth stuff it's not there
anymore
um so
what you need to do is to actually see
it
you need to enable the passes
then we can go to z and we can just work
that slider
until it's where we want and
you know
we'll get a little bit of
we can basically just get like a cut out
of our fish this is this is fine this
will work in photoshop we'll be able to
to grab this foreground
asset
bam yeah that's perfect cool
um where do we want to put it that's a
good question
oh that's a little sneak peek isn't it
hey
um let's do
bam export
or z
and we'll do uh
exr
[Music]
where'd you go bam open exr 32 sure
export
um
beauty cool and then we'll do uh
octane
settings heck no we'll do 2000 samples
set the gi clamp to one
that should all be fine
and just
because i'm curious before we close it
out
i'm gonna make this like a
translucent
plastic
just real quick
because why not
whoa
that's crazy
dude that's a whole
freaking another god this i feel like
this has a million different versions
that's so cool
it's a little less apparent as to what
it is but like could you imagine this in
motion oh that'd be so cool
that's crazy
i could see a version where we actually
have
every other one
so it's a mix
and of course we could try
dude i could just mess with this forever
uh we could try like a
a darker one
and drop that
on every other
but that just
yeah it's okay
certainly a style i think the
the white pops the most
pork spoon knife
the floss pick maybe we'll just do a
green
lost pick
um
it's always like this bright green
with some
[Music]
transmission
it's the touch yeah
uh
do that for the floss pick the straw can
just
be translucent
where you vamp straw sauce top
same
and
maybe the same
for the bottom
that's kind of cool that's some
variation to it you can still tell it's
a fish
i like that
and then let me just before we wrap it
out
let me make sure you can really tell
what these things are
yeah a little bit larger we kind of lose
the eye
so maybe we take this down to like
four thousand
three thousand
and we can work the the seed
oh that's a nice eye
see that one you couldn't even tell
a lot of these you can't tell that one's
not bad
that one's actually not bad either
i'll just get rid of that in
photoshop see what the top looks like
not the best top
you gotta find the right the right
balance
that's not bad
i'll probably just lose that highlight
awesome
[Music]
whoa that's crazy
shoot
wow
that's nuts
that might be the move actually right
here
because you can really tell
what these things are
that's so cool
dang
all right
let's give it the oil render
let's be done in another time
and while we're at it y'all while this
goes let's hit up the
weekly challenge
winners for this week shall we
let's see if my camera will come back on
yeah
all righty
all right
so whether my camera comes back or not
there we go what's up y'all it might die
again
it might be a cable thing i don't know
um but let's uh let's hop into it
let's just hop right in um first up we
got
the weekly challenge winner we got mitch
mitch popping off
this week um the theme was what was the
theme was white
the theme was white
um i freaking love what you did here man
absolutely terrifying um
definitely reminds me of being trapped
in some elden ring caves with some ants
or some spiders i do not like it
one bit
um i love your detail here your lighting
is great your freaking your camera angle
is solid you're getting across a bunch
of info
you chose the perfect camera angle for
this
um i would assume a pretty wide angle
lens
like the wispies underneath like how are
you doing that if you're here mitch
mitch i don't know if you are but
uh yeah visual agreed insane render dude
um
and those nasty old body sacks that's
disgusting
y'all remember resident evil 4 when
you're in the jail
and like
there's that sack
and you're like what's that and it just
wiggles and that's it
that they never talked about it after
that that was
kind of what that reminds me of anyway
moving on
second winner of the weekly challenge
this week is
bam mdk himself
one of the moderators um
so what you all get when you win you
receive 15 points to your role on the
discord server the link to the discord
server is down below if you all want to
participate in these weekly challenges
um then get creatine every single week
there's a new one
um
mdk what i love about this
this might be my favorite idea
um of the
challenge
this week because
the whole city was painted white it was
bland and these guys are coming through
uh looks like guys and gals are coming
through
and they're just painting the city up i
think that idea is incredible you should
be proud of it this really cool stuff
you executed it very very well
um your lighting is solid your color
solid the idea is solid the execution is
solid camera angle etcetera etcetera
textures dude you knocked it out
congratulations man 15 points to you
i feel like
freaking dumbledore giving out house
points um
moving on
we have
who do we got we got jack the hack this
is i think my favorite
submission
of the weekly challenge this week uh
again the the prompt was white and
this is incredible i think you did an
amazing job i feel the
the power the intensity feels very
visceral to me
i feel the weight and the spring of this
character in the clothes in the way the
piano is crushed into the ground your
lighting is incredible i don't know
where you got the idea from but it's a
10 out of 10 for me man jack the hat
congratulations for winning this week's
weekly challenge 15 points to you
next up we got two more
who do we got we have
noodle chan this
is on
the be believable this is some art right
here my friends
um this is freaking crazy a bunch of
different things that could be said
about this piece
um in terms of the emotion in terms of
the message
um
the freaking render quality is absurd
the skin shader is absurd i don't know
where you got this idea from but it's
freaking incredible
the only thing
that kills me about this one
noodle is
there is no rim light there's no edge
light along the back of this dude's head
and i know
it's there
but i'm not seeing it you need that rim
light on his hair on the back
otherwise 10 out of 10 for me dude
absolutely beautiful
and finally
this week's weekly challenge we have
edward
with this beautiful
render here
your attention to detail is amazing the
dust on top of the table
um different like specs and
pieces of uh of grass and of course rose
petals there's a letter there there's a
whole story going on with this render i
love it it's lit beautifully it's
presented beautifully
your textures are insane your
imperfections on the glass are insane
the moss the dirt
yeah this one's nuts edward
congratulations this might be your first
weekly challenge when
um if i'm not mistaken
i could be mistaken but who knows
congratulations to you it is
beautiful
and you know how we do y'all we got some
honorable mentions to get into
um because there are just some pieces of
art that are so sick
they didn't win but
i gotta shout them out so who do we got
uh mod of
ramesh
so you say you modeled and textured this
horse from scratch it looks beautiful
dude you should be very very proud of
this
and it's so well lit too your background
is incredible i love that uh
that there's inconsistencies in the
background color
that actually looks like a like a
backdrop that you put back there i don't
know if that's just like a noise map
or
a
displacement map that you put or like
some sort of deformer you put on the
mesh
it looks amazing and
dude you killed it with this
killed it congratulations sia
um who's next who do we got honorables
honorables
visual
dude this one seemed came so freaking
close to winning
goodness man
this is incredible
i love it
i don't know she's albino or something
she's got the white eyebrows the white
hair
of course you're crushing it with the
character work man the clothes look
incredible the focus is so crisp and
sharp i love it
this is an absolutely incredible piece
of work man good one for the portfolio
super solid uh by the way everyone who's
uh getting honorable mention i believe
it is five points
um to all of you guys
so you still get a little rank up here
on the honorable mentions
next up
we have volde
if i can see is it's very small on the
screen but it looks like volde
this is super cool man um it looks very
clean and it is lit beautifully i love
how you have that like spotlight effect
on the background and then it falls off
to a vignette
that is
freaking perfect very very beautiful
um
i love too it's very very subtle but you
have this gold stitching
and like a gold zipper i feel like you
could have used a little bit more gold
in
your render
um
because i still would have got the white
thing that would have been awesome
um but i don't know if it's like gold
hair gold eyes gold lips gold shirt gold
something i don't know but gold backdrop
i don't who knows
but the white and gold is a nice feel i
think you could just went a little bit
further on the gold there
um
who's next we got soul nate i believe
yeah
uh when i was looking at these uh
sotomante was joining me and he said it
reminds me of like the batman layer and
i was like you know what it totally does
totally does it looks photoreal
your lighting is killer
your setup is killer
it's got to be batman inspiration right
it can't not be it looks really freaking
good
um so shout outs to you
uh
uh soul nate sorry i saw you papaxo in
the chat
uh polar bear polar bear roar
probably not your name
probably the name of the art
so remember to name
your renders please name your renders as
your discord handle so i can shout you
out so you can get your points
don't want to miss out on your points
because you're getting points i love
this one
uh your lighting is killer i love how
you're
silhouetting the bear with the moon and
it's also backlit too you have that
really nice crispy
edge light there is perfect i think you
probably could have used a little bit
more work on the left side of the frame
maybe you could have scooted the moon
towards the left a little bit more too i
feel like
that probably would have been a little
nicer it feels really scrunched up
against the bear
um
yeah the left side is just lacking a
little bit but the lighting on the bear
is so freaking good it looks beautiful i
just had to shout you out this is good
stuff uh one dead duck is next
of course with your uh
with your photo realism it looks very
beautiful
um good framing good composition
i like the way you lit it you set it up
so that it was actually like looked like
it could feasibly happen and good
character work too
mccain
is next yeah
i like your composition here i think
it's really cool
uh i'm i'm a sucker for symmetrical
kind of layouts i think the tv white
noise on the tv
uh is pretty clever
so i think i think it's worthy of a
shout out we got uh jonas j
up next this one's super cool i love
your render quality film grain of course
good stuff
um your composition is solid your
lighting is pretty darn solid as well
the only thing that kind of threw me off
here was
it didn't feel too much like it followed
the prompt
of white
i was trying to figure out like the is
it the blanket ah
yeah i don't know maybe i'm missing
something but anyway it's an honorable
man good good honorable mention there
for you
who's next hamsu
uh dude you're
you're framing your composition
your lighting
really nice i love how you're using some
fog behind the character to silhouette
the horse
that's such a solid move
of course you got your bright white
light on the right side tentacles or you
know
going up towards that um i feel like you
maybe
i don't know
maybe could use like
some lightning in the sky or something
or not lightning but like
you could brighten up
the mid-tones of the clouds on the left
side a little more
or edge lit the building itself
where the building meets the sky it's
like
a little
dark
on the left side
maybe you could hit them with like a
moon a brighter moonlight or something
just to pop them out
maybe an edge light
on the
entire left terrain
and the characters themselves maybe
but yeah i dig your colors take your
composition take the idea
um we have festy cadaver
next this one
i love the lighting
really dig the lighting i think it could
be cropped a little bit from the bottom
you can crop the bottom off there's i'm
also missing some detail on the ground
plane
this one feels like it's kind of low
detail but
has an interesting filter on it like the
background looks interesting
your lighting is solid that again that's
what i really like about this
and your tones are really cool too
i dig
the darkness of the hood
the grim reaper is
the brightest point
of the image which is totally the case
or should be the case because he is he
or she is the subject or it
i don't know if a grim reaper
has a gender of any sort but
yeah this one's cool um eloy we got you
next with the honorable
santorini um very good stuff
this one just felt
like it was lacking some detail you went
in on an idea that had a lot of detail
and you started to go in on
some detail
on the
left tower
i feel like if you're gonna go on in on
some detail
on that tower it feels like the whole
thing needs detail now
so you probably could have simplified
that left tower and kept it just like
simple simple
and it would have
felt like it would have fit a little bit
more
um
because yeah it's like i need something
i need like people walking around here
uh
i think it just needs to be filled out a
little bit more
but i really like it i've always wanted
to go to this place
uh and there's actually a really fun
game i think it's called santorini
i think it's called st train it's a
board game it's like a stackable 3d
chess kind of thing it's super fun
and the art is beautiful
and this might be our
second to last honorable we have east
adam
shout out
this one
also came close to winning
um
i feel like it was lacking a subject
um
it's a super solid render though like
your photo realism
is 10 out of 10.
your lighting is very nice too
your textures are beautiful your
materials are beautiful
and uh
it's you know pretty pretty good idea
repainting the wall white yeah i get it
totally
but man that photo realism is top notch
good stuff and finally the last
honorable for y'all is casual night
i love the idea i don't know if you like
i don't know where you got this idea
if it came off the top of your dome or
what but i think it is incredible
there's a golden idea right here
yeah
i think that's that's about all i have
to say about that
super solid congratulations to all you
guys um
for winning the weekly challenge
for the honorable mentions keep it up
please this week's theme i believe is
swamp
um so head on over to the discord server
link is in the description
and join us on the weekly challenge this
week get your swamp renders popping off
um but i have uh
an image
to tweak in photoshop before i go i
promised you all that so
let's hop into it
all right the image is done
let's open up photoshop
and
do a thing
alrighty
so
this is funny this is actually the first
iteration of the thumbnail
that i put together
[Music]
and i'm like this doesn't feel like this
just feels like death
[Music]
so i went with
the thumb as you guys saw this was the
first version of the thumbnail well
technically the second version of the
thumbnail
this is what the thumbnail ended up
being
it has the darker tones on it which i
really dig
um
and
let's see
where we at where we at bam
and this is what we got
let me open up that z depth as well
yo okay so this is the thing i don't
know how
to extract z depth stuff in photoshop i
know there is a plug-in which was on my
old computer
which would let me do it but i
don't have it on this computer so
maybe we just don't do that
pardon me
all right let's do
we don't need all these bits
uh because i don't even think i can go
into
camera raw with 32 bits
let me see
ctrl shift a
yeah visual open exr i think that is
what i had
thanks for that
because i forgot what it was called
let's go to
mode and change it to 16 bit
ctrl shift a will bring us into
camera raw
where i like to do my stuff
and you know what here before we do that
let me right click and
convert to a smart object
that way
we aren't baking in any sort of stuff
all right
let's hit up
our curves yeah
double click to reset that
yeah that's nice
that feels pretty good
[Music]
[Music]
and i'm just
trying to bring out the difference
between the shadows and the highlights
to really just shape this fish
and maybe something like that
clarity could help too
texture
kind of pop out
the details we don't need too much
because it kind of gets a little
chunky
um i'm happy
with
the color
so let's go
ahead maybe see about a vignette
we already kind of have one
but let me see what i can do let's
feather the crap out of it
i don't know if it needs it
yeah i don't i honestly don't think it
needs it
all right
so there's the
difference
with our edits
we just punched it up
and
i would love
to add some film green to it of course
you all know
so i'm gonna open up
i just got this from google
um
overlays
i got two kinds
is it really that small
shoot
hold on let me redo this
i wonder if there's a fit to screen
option in photoshop
there's gotta be
right click
oh
[Music]
film grain
is a subtle thing you don't want to go
too hard on it
set it to overlay
both of these to
overlay that brightens up i don't like
that
this does the job
yeah that looks nice
and let's flip it so it's brighter up
towards the top
that's funny this actually looks like
some caustics in the film grain
that's perfect
yeah i feel like you just need some like
text
[Music]
i don't know
[Music]
who knows
i don't want to be too cringy with it
you know
i think uh
subtlety is good here
that's crazy
i'm a fan of this i am going to get rid
of some of these the floaters here
um so
i'm going to duplicate this
let's see
ctrl j duplicates
make a new layer it's like both of them
merge
just a quick way to make it rasterable
and i think we can do this with the
healing
brush
spot healing tool
yeah just get rid of these like floaters
[Music]
[Music]
because again i want it to look
i want it to look real
oh
yeah
yeah we're gonna clean up that eye
[Music]
um i think that's all the floaters
that i see
[Music]
let's get the eye
popping off um
what's the best way to do this
[Music]
[Music]
and then i think i can do
potentially
burn tool
or i wonder
i'll duplicate this again
[Music]
uh let's go filter sharpen unsharp mask
uh we'll make a what is this called
a layer mask we'll make a layer mask
with the layer mask selected i'll hit
ctrl i
[Music]
so it
it takes it off completely
we'll choose a white brush
and just paint it on
that looks like garbage
all right let's try another method
maybe i just crease increase the
highlights around this part
dodge tool highlights
yeah
mid-tones
because what we need to do is
essentially make this blue part darker
and everything else a little bit
brighter
hmm
i don't know it's not bad
it's not bad at all
um
we really wanted to get in there i mean
just do it right
it's pen tool time
[Music]
all right path to selection
let's do a test while we're at it
so bam there's my selection here
and we can
darken this image
just a bit
all right so here's the other test
here's the other test the other test is
to duplicate it
[Music]
let's delete that mask
still dark okay
the other test is to magic wand
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i guess minus that piece
you can probably just touch it up a
little bit
[Music]
there god dang it
[Music]
and we do the same
the magic wand is a touch softer
but saved us a lot more time
and i think
that is a much cleaner eye
that totally works oh maybe one last
thing we can do is
accentuate those arrays a little bit
more so let's go with the
burn tool will go mid-tones
real subtle on it
oh i just realized too shoot i just
realized um
that
i think
those floaters
was part of this
dang it and i baked it ah that's why you
don't bake stuff okay
no but it's darker because i baked the i
baked the levels into the image
that's why you don't bake the levels
all right um
spot
um
[Music]
man this looks so awesome i'm really
proud of this
i feel like it's been a minute since
i've made a piece of art on stream that
i was really proud of
[Music]
okay and then we
use a black brush
and erase this eye part
feel like that can just use
a little less
just pretty subtle there
yeah
and finally
let's go ahead and bring out these rays
a little bit more
all right burn tool
pretty large
[Music]
and i wonder if this will work if i
go to
image now select subject
[Music]
this is when that z depth mask will be
great
honestly
[Music]
even subtler
[Music]
and then let's go to
dodge tool and hit
those mid-tones
[Music]
[Music]
sweet
[Music]
very very nice
i like that a lot
evolver yo dude
you're back thanks again man
so generous so kind of you thank you
thank you thank you i know i'm really
proud of this one dude
i felt this turned out really well
um let's go with a gray brush
so we just kind of drop the opacity or
you know i'll go with a black brush with
just a low opacity
over the mask itself
and that way i can kind of just
make the rays not as subtle or not as
obvious yeah that's good
bridgey we did camera raw we did camera
raw at the beginning actually um what i
will do though i think this wood is a
little dark
so i'm going to try and bring that back
let me duplicate that hop in
to the camera raw
what the heck
do
there we go
and i'm just gonna
let's see how do we want to do this yes
we want those on but we want to do a
layer mask and we want to invert it
so we are back to our normal image here
bam with
this no just that
and i want to just paint on the shadow
so
i'll go with a real light
brush a
very soft brush
low opacity
make it a white brush
because we're painting a mask down here
it's really small but i have this black
mask selected so i want to paint white
to see through it
and it's a low opacity white brush
all right way too subtle
uh
all right i'm not seeing it because of
one of these guys
we'll get there
[Music]
much better
much better
there's our eye
there's this bit which i need to erase
to reveal what we did down here
that's about done
bam
[Music]
sweet i'm happy with that
i'm very happy with that
heck yeah
that'll probably be the new thumbnail
all right export
[Music]
boom
and we're done we are done y'all
thank you guys thank you for joining me
that was fun
i can't wait to take this idea and like
keep doing stuff with it i think there's
a whole lot of stuff to do different
animals
i had that whale at the beginning of the
stream i know i want to get that up and
go in
um but
we did it yeah we made a fish it looks
like a fish and you can actually see
that it's made of plastic
single-use plastics so y'all if you guys
want to know a little bit more about
recycling and
um how to keep trash out of the ocean if
that matters to you all
or if you're just curious about it i did
link that book that i told you all about
at the beginning stream it's in the
description it's called can i recycle
this
uh and it blew my mind this is not a
sponsored stream this is just me
being me all right
um it blew my mind i learned a whole lot
about recycling i didn't know
most of what i read in that book um it
was super cool to read and i feel better
off now
um
yeah
get a water bottle buy stuff um and
reuse stuff that
you find yourself going through
constantly and
you know no more no more of this stuff
you just hold hold this stuff
at the restaurant when they try and give
it to you when you're ordering takeout
um
what else
i'm not i'm not trying to preach too
hard um
but it is something that i've started to
get passionate about
pretty recently in the last like six
months or so
um thanks for joining me i hope you guys
learned some stuff both about recycling
and about 3d i was really happy with
this art i think it turned out well i'll
chill with y'all for another
five minutes or so and hang out uh
answer any questions you guys might have
it's a good one
it's a good one tinum thank you i'm
really happy with the end result as well
i think it turned out really nice
the ocean cleanup i'll look that up
melanie never heard of that before i
will take a look into that thank you
very much
what uh film stock do i like using
melvin i love cinestill 800t that's a
really good one their black and white
50d is good as well portrait 400 is a
classic
um t-max
i believe t-max 400 is a really nice
black and white contrasty stock um so
that's a good one
uh lolmantv is this a challenge no not a
challenge i'm just
creating art on the stream today just
doing a one-off
um
mitch mitch you should launch a 3d
challenge of creating renders from
plastic like you did in the stream could
be cool
it's interesting you know it'd be sweet
to raise some money
for some ocean cleanup stuff if you all
are into that
i know i am um
i i have been getting a million and one
requests about am i gonna do an nft blah
blah
i think the only way to do an nft for a
challenge
is to
donate the money don't eat all the money
uh i could see
doing a challenge
something like this
uh
minting it selling it as an nft and
donating it to
some sort of ocean cleanup thing i could
see that i don't know curious to hear
what you guys think about that but
um
yeah i love this i love this like i i
when i had the idea in my head i was
like oh my god
i gotta do this
it's a super cool idea
um
so i i think i i want to do a couple
other versions of this
i think it'll be really cool
i love that underwater
move i was not expecting the underwater
move
that was good
where do i get inspiration for creating
art luke ah man anywhere and everywhere
uh
music i love listening to music that
helps me
traveling going out visiting places i've
never been to before
that helps me too
at a certain point like
i think getting inspiration from your
adventures your life
um versus looking at other people's art
will
come up with more like unique results
the more you can like look in towards
you for inspiration
i think your art will be more unique
sorry y'all i'm out of water
at this point
lucas
thank you my friend
freaking very generous of you guys i'm
getting a pizza after this son
i'm gonna get a pizza my favorite pizza
of all time i'm going there
thank you guys thank you for the pizza
money
much appreciated
much much appreciated
um it all also helps me
pay my boy soda monte on the other line
on the other end of this he's helping
switch up the stream yeah yeah
he's working the stream
so we get our boy soda monte paid as
well so i really appreciate that i know
soda does too thank you guys
um when am i going to europe the next
time oh my god i would love to go back
to europe
uh
i don't know this year
who knows i wanna i wanna get there for
real
i miss traveling so much my goodness
um are these the riddler's glasses i
have no idea i got them on zenny optical
you all have asked me that in the past
it's any optical you get some cheap
glasses there
um
what else
oh man hybrids yeah i've seen that short
film that was that was great
that was a great short i love that uh
just look up hybrids 3d short film
this is good stuff
very good stuff
very much in line with what we're doing
right now actually
um italy is waiting for me oh i want to
go so bad
i want to visit so bad
man vienna ooh melanie
vienna oh my god would be amazing spain
yes soto
that whole area that whole area like i
don't really know geography until i go
to a place and i like i'm forced to like
look at the map and like oh this is here
this is here this is here and i think
all that stuff is like pretty you can
hop on a train and like hit all that
stuff right
maybe i'm just making stuff up
but that would be sweet
um
what else y'all any other questions
before i bounce before i get a
pizza pizza
thanks big ben i'm glad you enjoyed the
stream i'm glad you enjoyed the art i
know i had a great time making it was
fun making this with you guys
super cool
oh bone conduction don't get me started
on those bone conduction headphones
they're the best all right is it a
useful gadget it's the best gadget
yeah these guys bam
we ain't sponsored this is not a sponsor
stream but i will go to the grave with
these these are the aftershocks aeropex
bone conduction open ear
headphones um
they basically add a soundtrack to your
life
you're able to hear other thing you're
you know it's just like walking
going about life oh but there's music in
my brain that is the weirdest thing ever
sometimes you forget you're wearing them
they are the best
yeah really good for hikes
good for any anything really good for
anything
um
what are the best pizza toppings
my dude um
well the place i've been going to they
have a pizza from ev not every country
but like all 20 of their pizzas are from
like a different country um so they have
like a tikka masala pizza there's no
pepperoni on that thing
all right but if i'm just talking like
classic pizza give me some pepperoni
give me some basil
and
uh give me some
oregano
give me some crushed red pepper or
some jalapeno
uh
what else is good on a pizza
tikka masala pizza
pineapple i used to be like yo get that
pineapple off my pizza
but
i think i've been converted recently ham
can stay away i do not i'm not a ham guy
i'll do some pepperoni and pineapple
that i'll get down with for sure
prosciutto down
yeah absolutely
pepperoni s tear yeah like a cheese
pizza i don't got the time
give me something a little bit more
garlic powder yo how about just straight
up garlic cloves
um
any other questions y'all any oh yo so i
went to this place
this place
fat tony's
in whistler
when i went uh to whistler over to
christmas break
uh last year
go to fat tony's if you're in whistler
go to fat tony's oh my god
that pizza was insane
um
they had a so my fiance she can't do
she uh she basically on a vegan diet
basically
best vegan pizza she's ever had
also they put sesame seeds like on their
crust so when you get to the crust
forget that cheese filled crust nah i'm
like i like a little thin crust okay
but a little something they threw sesame
seeds on there oh my god it was so good
i think they had a they had a butter
chicken pizza too
get yourself to fat tony's if you're in
whistler canada vancouver go to fat
tony's they're insane
salmon pizza with sour cream
ugh
i'm sorry
sorry but that sounds rough melody oh
monkfish pizza toppings
yo okay
uh tiger demon you mentioned korean food
okay this place i'm talking about they
have
uh they have which one call it um
a bulgogi
pizza it's like a i think it's bulgogi
pizza it's amazing oh my god it's
amazing
so good
you thought i was standing yeah i know
i'm i'm in a chair
i'm in a big old chair
ah
[Music]
all right what else y'all hit me some
questions
which program should i learn first maxon
cinema 4d or unreal engine you want to
learn i'd say
to be honest man
unreal is there
unreal is steep
unreal i look tiny huh let me lower this
that's better unreal is a steep program
okay
i don't i'm not trying to scare you or
anything but it's it's deep if you're
trying to learn unreal
check out winbush check out uh
um
william foshee
all right both of those guys the best
um if you're trying to learn cinema 4d
i learned through
um
i design
ej over at i design
i learned through grayscale gorilla
um those were the those were the guys
for me
and then of course yeah you got blender
blender's free
blender guru
um what are some other good blender
tutorials
uh blender guru is like the only one i
can think of at the off the top of my
head but there's there's more out there
cg matter cg geek thank you sotomante i
appreciate it i got him in my ear he's
here he's here to stay
um
yeah i evolver i agree with you learn
general skills first like i think you
should learn how to 3d model you should
learn to texture you should learn to
light you should learn to work your
camera all that kind of stuff
learn your basics
and then go from there
i think it's solid
oh yeah ian hubert of course
he's got the speedy tutorials i think
it's a little bit more intermediate
style oh yeah peter france too peter
france has some good blender tutorials
that guy's a freaking genius
um
hey tiger demon good to know
composition and lighting are your
biggest flaws
i'd say composition and lighting makes a
render
to be honest with you um
you can have bad everything else but if
the composition and the lighting is
solid you're gonna have some
sick stuff for sure
so it's good you know what your
weaknesses are
uh so that you can work on them
have i ever used 3ds max yes i used 3ds
max for 6 years
um
i started in c4d in r10
about 12 years ago
i switched to 3ds max because all the
tutorials were for 3ds max and i was
like pissed i was like
why
there are no c4d
tutorials um so i switched to 3ds max
for six years because that's what sam
and nico were using that's what freddie
and brandon were using
and then
uh yeah four years ago switch back to
c4d
um so
yeah 3ds max is tough
it's like opening
i don't know it's like opening like a
doctor's program
there's just like
it's the blandest
program
uh
the tiniest little square buttons with
the tiny text and i'm like god dang
but we made it work for six years
and it wasn't bad
now
like transitioning from one program to
another
if you're like for real about it you're
like you know what i'm not going to use
this anymore i'm going to use this
it'd probably just take a couple weeks
to be honest you hit your tutorials
learn how to navigate learn where your
stuff is it's like you just moved your
house and all your stuff is in different
drawers different rooms so once you can
find it and remember where everything is
then
it'll be a pretty easy switch you know
what else y'all
what else
thanks chris i appreciate that
oh funny all right have i been seeing
open i ai dolly stuff that's funny um
sodamonte mentioned that yesterday when
we were prepping the stream
um
yeah super cool i've been messing with
this program called
conjure and it's been incredible
um
it's conjure dot art
and you type in whatever you want and it
produces
some crazy ai generated art and i think
it's perfect for coming up with ideas
like i really want to start using that
as my concept and uh
i think i'll probably work that into
maybe one of my next renders one of my
next real renders i'll start just coming
up with ideas with the ai art
um and
go from there i think it'll be a really
cool way to make something
when am i coming to the maya class i
will not be coming to the maya class i
refute i refuse to come to my class
no i'm just kidding um
no
no
it's time to go i guess
um
i don't know what
what's up y'all
my camera's overheating y'all it's time
to go
um no i'm i'm not trying to learn maya
i'm trying to learn unreal engine
uh i'm gonna try i'll try and get better
at c4d i got that modeling course i'm
working on
um
and then i want to learn substance
painter
yeah
but y'all
i'mma get that pizza i'll see you guys
later thank you so much for stopping by
it was a good stream it was nice hanging
out with you guys thank you all for the
super chats
evolver i love you dude thank you thank
you thank you
um
and there was one other there was one i
mean all you guys all you guys
i can't pick and choose y'all are
beautiful everyone's beautiful all right
guys i i'm just like rambling at this
point
i'll see you later
peace out
see you next week next week next week
doing a stream next week
um i love this is a talking fish
hold on
can we do this right now
i'm just gonna try and do this right now
this is so stupid
this is gonna be so stupid
uh
this is so stupid
is it worth it it's worth it it's worth
it it's worth it
so dumb
all right so next week um
i'm doing a live stream i'm gonna use
the looking glass portrait and i'm gonna
make a piece of art in c4d or unreal i'm
gonna be joined by a guest potentially
um
and we're gonna make a cool little
looking glass portrait thing and pop it
on to the
looking glass and hopefully you guys can
download it
at the end of the stream if you guys
have a looking glass
other than that
yeah um
anyway where was i i was being stupid
other than that um
i think that's it i'll see you guys next
week 10 45. until next time goodbye
[Music]
10.
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you